let's talk about this movie most wanted
interesting role for you
um you're playing kind of a scumbag in
this yes i play
a two-timing drug dealer again
so you know i'm guilty of being type
cast
uh it's it's an amazing story it's uh it
really kind of
uh it's about a guy who was framed
because during the
the peak of the war on drugs uh they
really were looking for
uh to bring down a kingpin so they
pinned it on this
guy in his early 20s and i'm i set him
up because i'm that kind of guy
you betray you betray this person and
um um you you don't seem to have much of
a moral compass is that fair to say
that's fair to say it's uh
and you know dealing with scumbags
um i i just you know i to prepare i just
thought of like
what would conan do okay
you've gone at me maybe 40 times in this
interview
and i've i've you know i put up with a
zucchini
i put up with the constant jabs um
you know it's my insecurity it's just
it's just i get nervous i get nervous
i feel like there's not enough of me
kind of like there's not enough shirt
for you
but you know i just put a shirt on i'm
sorry
i'm sorry i put a shirt on they've been
great called they need their clothes
back okay yeah
guess what the guy who owns your
shirt called and said he's mistaken it's
not your shirt
it looks like he's living completely
i don't think this can air you don't
have to do any of this editing do you
no no there won't be any editing i want
this to go out
just as is because i think it will
finish you in the business
it will finish you you'll be done you
know you'll be lucky to get one car in
your drive-in comedy shows
you'll be on channel 900 on sirius
we'll be talking into uh you'll be
talking into uh a summer root vegetable
oh don't you
we have we have a clip here from most
wanted you want to set it up for us
yeah i play this guy in this movie
i didn't know that there was a clip okay
i don't know anything about the clip
because i was supposed to look at it on
my iphone and i didn't
on someone like this
[Laughter]
well anyway i
we should we should uh we have a clip
here
and man is this a good clip take a look
at this clip this is jim gaffigan
uh pretty much playing himself a
two-timing soulless
drug-dealing scumbag here he is in most
wanted
jesus christ you told them ten thousand
for aquila
that you said they wanted a source you
didn't say a goddamn thing about me
going to thailand
you bought tons of heroin in thailand i
bought it over two months and i smoked
it all there
what yeah i don't know how you want me
to go to thailand i don't have any cash
i don't know you're going
you're going to find them a source do
not make me look bad in front of these
people or i will
skin you alive and we're back
did you like the clip it was pretty good
it was pretty good
um i felt like i remember
shooting that scene and i was like what
would
conan do you know what i mean right
if he had more clothes that fit him okay
okay okay this shirt used to fit me
and then i you know got a little jacked
but you know like there is a 13 year old
girl that's looking for her shirt right
now
and do you know what i mean
when you were putting it on and there
was a training bra inside it did you
think this might not be much
i i was suspicious i was suspicious that
maybe i should take it out
um you're right shirt's too small
the makeup's off um
yeah it's all a mess and i apologize
you